arrière du monument aux morts
complètement saccagé comme si l'objectif
premier de cet acte c'était de faire
tomber l'édifice cela faisait un an et
demi qu'il avait été installé à deux pas
de l'église du bourg c'était l'une des
promesses de campagne du nouveau maire
et la nuit dernière il a été cassé comme
si ceux qui l'avaient saccagé souhaitait
effacer de la mémoire collective le nom
des anciens combattants de vie à pilote
j'avais pris la décision une fois élu
d'installer un monument aux morts et de
récupérer les noms des anciens qui de
figure pas sur l'ancien monument pour
faire savoir nous avons plus de 150
compatriotes qui sont partis en 15 15 16
pour aller faire la guerre et qui sont
pas revenus
historiquement c'est un fait majeur nous
avons rencontré le maire de la commune à
Lens figuier avec ses collaborateurs il
mettait en place un plan d'évacuation
d'urgence en cas de tsunami et
concernant le Monument aux Morts son
avis semble bien tranché je ne touche
pas je la stèle que c'est je ne touche
pas je ne veux pas alors le seul risque
effectivement parce que c'est un peu
fissuré il y a un risque de danger pour
pour que ça tombe et je pense que c'est
ceux qui ont cherché à faire à faire
tomber mais c'était convenablement
scellé donc ils ont eu du mal à mon avis
à déceler et j'ai envie de laisser sans
l'État pour que la population se rende
compte de la bêtise d'une partie de
notre compatriotes quel que soit la
cause que l'on défend on ne s'en prend
pas l'histoire ça c'est l'histoire
ce monument aux morts devrait garder ses
cicatrices pendant encore quelques mois
le temps que le conseil municipal est le
maire de Rivière Pilote décide ou pas de
le changer